i'm sure you all saw the super bowl
close game talented young quarterbacks
down to the last drive
in the end there could only be one champ
so congrats to the la rams for lifting
the lombardi trophy
but like all games it wasn't without a
little controversy
there was a missed pass interference
call on the bengals big touchdown to
start the second half
maybe
did they call a ticky tac pass
interference on the bengals to set up
the last rams touchdown
probably
these things can go either way but they
usually even out in the end the
officials had a good game they let him
play which isn't always the case
that's corn misconduct that's a warning
it was an accident come on i thought she
was in play not a chance we're sweating
like grease monkeys out here
but what happens if the refs don't throw
flags on one team
what if they only penalize the bengals
while the rams just march up and down
the field even worse what if the refs
partnered up with one of the teams
seems totally unfair right
well that's essentially what happened
with the 2016 election
the refs of our political system the
media
fbi and the intelligence community not
only failed to keep hillary clinton in
check they connive together
the country's still dealing with the
consequences
it's been no secret that hillary refused
to accept the results of the election
trump knows he's an illegitimate
president
i do think that he knows uh that
he's an illegitimate president
and because of that he is
he's he's very uh insecure about it
look what he's trying to do now and part
of the ukraine scandal that is slowly
coming to light is he's trying to figure
out how to say no no it wasn't the
russians even though our intelligence uh
community and everyone who's looked at
this said yeah yeah it was the russians
he's trying to say no somehow it was you
know the old you know obama hillary you
know whoever hillary's been unable to
move on and now we know why
she's just sticking with her story you
can't change an alibi
this weekend special counsel john durham
dropped a bombshell report
they don't call her crooked for nothing
durham's team filed in court and if
there was ever any doubt that clinton
was behind the russia hoax that's
officially gone
durham's documents show that hillary
clinton hired people who hacked
into trump's home and office computers
before and during his presidency
and planted evidence that he colluded
with russia
yeah you heard that right
hillary broke into a presidential
candidate's computer server and a
sitting president's computer server
spying on him
there her hackers planted evidence
fabricated evidence connecting trump to
russia then fed that doctored material
to the feds and the media
at first she just did this to distract
from her own email scandal but then when
trump beat her she used this hoax as an
excuse for losing
this launched a criminal investigation
aimed at taking down a sitting president
hillary clinton broke the law to frame
trump as a russian trader
the media the so-called umpires of our
democracy went along with the frame job
for years they backed up whatever lies
hillary was spewing about donald trump
the president is a russian operative
this cloud about collusion with russia
will hang over him no matter where he
stands it does look like he's listening
to putin more than he is american
intelligence we're about to find out if
the new president of our country is
going to do what russia wants the
presidency is effectively a russian op
and when some real information came to
light like the fact that the steele
dossier was as phony as my eighth grade
girlfriend who supposedly went to
another school
they doubled down on their denial
and they trashed john durham's
investigation into their own lives
listen
the biggest scandal was when they spied
on my campaign they spied on my campaign
there's no real evidence of that of
course there is it's all over the place
leslie they spied on my campaign and
they got called donald trump and william
barr promised that durham would expose
huge corruption but he hasn't done that
is apparently an ongoing concerted
republican and pro-trump project
to try to turn the investigation of the
russia scandal into some kind of scandal
itself oh no okay wait till the dual
report comes out and
and then nothing happens and they just
move on to the next conspiracy theory
the media failed the police hillary the
dirty cop of politicians as she pushed
an insurrection
the left loves to memorialize january 6
as an attack on our democracy but if
that's true then what's this
the russia hoax and the three-year
mueller investigation did more to
undermine faith in our democracy than
january 6th
look at the impact it's had on our
country
the credibility of the fbi and the cia
shattered
federal prosecutors at the department of
justice no longer trusted
a presidential campaign was broken into
was spied on
and who knows how the russia hoax
affected that race
the 2018 election was interfered with
the mueller investigation hung a dark
cloud over those midterms costing
republicans the house
the nation was divided
our foreign policy was affected and it
led to some arguments that ruined quite
a few waters family holidays
durham's probe has cost 10 percent of
what mueller's has
and with less time and resources he
found the smoking gun
was mueller trying to find answers or
was he covering the left's tracks we
know the answer mueller was a mop-up job
and he was just there to tee up
impeachment
according to durham's filing this
hacking of trump dates all the way back
you ready to 2014.
well before he came down that golden
escalator
former director of national intelligence
john ratcliffe has revealed that
hillary's motives to frame trump were no
secret
the cia fbi the doj and even obama
himself
were briefed that the russia hoax was a
clinton dirty trick
but they all went along with it didn't
they
ratcliffe believes that there is more
than enough evidence for quote multiple
indictments
so who could be next
are james clapper and john brennan next
on the chopping block
they did a pretty good job of trying to
throw us off hillary's trail
listen to how they responded when former
attorney general william barr said in
congressional testimony he believed
trump was spied on
well i was very disappointed in what
attorney general barr said today about
spying when he was referring to the
investigation that was predicated
certainly and that the fbi was trying to
understand exactly what the russians
were doing i thought it was uh
both stunning and and scary
i was uh amazed at that and and rather
disappointed that
attorney general would say such a thing
that you know the term spying
has all kinds of negative connotations
and
i
i i have to believe he he chose that
term
deliberately yeah feds usually circle
the wagons around other feds so who
knows what's gonna happen to those two
clowns but this is a level of corruption
not seen in american history this is
more brazen than the watergate break-in
hillary's hackers broke in planted
evidence then got the feds to try
throwing a president out of office
isn't it time she faced the consequences
[Applause]
has the time finally come are we
witnessing the end of the clinton
dynasty one of the five families of the
democrat party
it looks like hillary's played her last
get out of jail free card
while bills felt the wrath of the me too
movement and lost his pilot's wings from
his days on jeffrey epstein's lolita
express
bill clinton was on those flights
numerous times on the flights that bill
clinton was on with jeffrey epstein the
stewardess
or stewardesses
many of them were underage were dressed
as candy stripers
correct
and there were beds in the back of the
plane
beds
bedroom
yes
even the clinton's phony charity
foundation has been exposed as a
pay-for-play scheme
sorry chelsea
but i think your parents
have left you high and dry hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else